sasha those
flames and smoke are truly illuminating
the sky here in the northwest valley
you can see those play our flames and
smoke rising up in the sky
but fortunately because of these strong
winds it's
pushing that smoke south or i'm sorry
northwest
so the smoke is not coming into the
valley it's getting pushed out
into the desert but it is creating quite
a scene here in sky canyon this is a
one thousand acre master plan community
uh this it is definitely
very gusty out here governor sissel like
i just saw is aware of this fire he
tweeted about it
and we do know that envy energy did shut
off the power
on mount charleston by request of
firefighters to help crews
battle the flames because as orco did
mention this is
not contained yet but the fire
definitely creating
quite a sight out here for anyone in the
northwest valley
and anyone across the valley who just
looks up to see
the smoke across the sky and it is
creating
quite an illusion just because on one
side here in the northwest you have the
orange and the gray and the darkness
and then if you just look over to the
south
clear blue skies the sun is shining
but as orco mentioned that sun is hidden
right now
by the plumes of smoke we're gonna have
the very latest on this fire coming up
as well stay with eight news now on our
facebook page as well as twitter
as we continue to cover this fire
throughout the evening reporting live
kristen drummond
8 news now